[Music]
hi I'm welcome to episode number 160 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark mantle and i'm here with my
colleague Gabby Ferrara hello Gabby how
you doing today hello mark I'm good how
are you I'm good thank you so much for
joining me on the podcast it's very
exciting to be working with you yeah
first time so let's see how that goes I
think it's gonna go great before we get
to the podcast do you want to tell
people a little bit about yourself just
so they get to know you so many buyer
here I'm a developer advocate at Google
cloud for storage another basis mostly
focusing on called sequel which it is
all for for my sequin poster Chris and
sometimes I do other stuff like make
memory store or getting in the middle of
stuff that's none of my business like a
native excellent yeah speaking of Kay
native that is what we're gonna be
talking about today so we will be
talking with villi and mark talking
about Canada and all the things you can
do about it and then after that we're
gonna have our usual question of the
week where I'm gonna ask you a question
about cloud sequel and how long it takes
to detect an outage and trigger high
availability failover are you ready okay
excellent
we always do our cool things of the week
yeah but you wanna go first with one of
your cool things the week so we are
opening a new renewable energy plant in
Asia right now we only had before in
Americas and you were yes so Google
announced they're doing a new renewable
energy plant in Asia and that's cool
because before you only had in America
and Europe so that's gonna be a 10
megawatt plans of solar array and I
don't know how much that power is but I
think if ours a lot of stuff on that I
think it's a lot yeah awesome and we'll
have a link to some details of that in a
blog post in the in the show notes as
well I'm really excited because we're
getting going with cloud functions
that's a terrible pun as well but go
home on point one is now a supported
language on cloud functions which makes
me really happy because I write really
terrible JavaScript and I try and write
Club functions and it's always a mess I
know I can write in a language that I'm
much more familiar with so if you want
to play with that that is available now
in beta which is awesome so you can
write HTTP functions with go you can run
it against events so if you're a go
lover like I am you can take advantage
of that right you know another cool
thing of the week it's the Google game
of the year which use a context to
speech API in App Engine and they talked
about how they were able to save costs
not having to hire a new actor every
time they needed to add a new stuff on
their game and also being scalable with
App Engine so give it a shot at that
plot votes there yeah you can actually
go straight to the link and bring it up
it's actually a really cute game that
you can play yeah I really like it it's
fun finally we also have a new blog post
series by fellow developer relations
person Megan O'Keefe who is a developer
programs engineer talking about sto so
it's a series of articles talking about
SEO and how it plugs into a variety of
things actually that I really like so
it's a basic discussion about sort of
having server smash I'm where that's
applicable but then also going into
where that's been integrated into things
like a native talking about multi
cluster sto or that kind of stuff so I'm
gonna have a link to the first one
that's in the show notes but keep an eye
out for follow-up articles after that
awesome
well Gabi why don't we go chat with our
guests and learn all about K native okay
Mexico so big thanks to March Marnie and
Billy I guess for joining us today to
talk about K native thanks so much for
joining us how you doing today really
I'm doing great thanks for having us I'm
really excited to talk about K native so
thanks for having us awesome and how you
doing Mike
doing good excited as well with Vela and
talking about Canada thank you for
having us fantastic awesome so before we
get stuck into K native do you wanna
tell us a little bit about who you are
and what you do
Billy why don't you go first I'm one of
the founders the K needed project that's
something that I've been working on for
the last year and a half almost now
prior to that I've been working on
several open source projects helm
kubernetes service catalog and so forth
and before that worked on kubernetes
before I could open sourced and Dennis T
in Google Cloud Storage so all cloud all
the time awesome mark you and Phillip
yeah I'm a technical program manager for
service at Google recently however has
been much more closer to a developer
advocate type of role working on a key
native open source project as well as
the GK add-on which is based on a native
that kind of transition of the role
really came from the early days where we
were super scrappy who had a small team
on Canadian
and everybody did two or three jobs but
as the team grows and we're bringing in
people on much more focus on a native
ecosystem driving community awareness
partners contributors speaking
engagements blogs and demos and so forth
so I'm excited to work more and more
with the outside contributors to Canada
okay thank you mark we're happy to have
you here to talk about key native and
that would be really happy to learn a
bit more about key native today because
my knowledge is a bit thing on this
subject I just know a bit of communities
and I'm really excited to see what you
have to show us about a subject here
yeah why don't you give us sort of a
high-level overview of like what's the
problem that Kay native is trying to
solve sure so one of the things that we
did with the kubernetes was really this
is my words I think we gave the cloud
and the developers assembly language for
the cloud yeah so you want to go and get
stuff up and running in the cloud the
instruction set if you will and provided
kubernetes and kubernetes is great
problem is that there's a lot of pieces
that you have to go ahead and understand
in order to effectively use it and for
the most part the developers don't
really need to know all those things
ideally but they are exposed to it in
order for them to actually get things up
and running so as we looked around for a
while we realized that there is the need
for a higher level abstraction at
kubernetes level that would allow us to
go ahead and meet the developers need
much more closely and that sort of kind
of Burdick a native comes so if you
think about the communities and even its
deal as well as kind of the assembly
language Kay native is bringing you
something like the Lipsy or standard lip
that's how I think about it so there's a
lot of the problems that are being
solved all over the place especially in
the server less space and be kind of
money to bring all of our friends and
all the knowledge and solve those
problems in one place and then go ahead
and focus and building super awesome
developer experiences on top of that if
I could just maybe add something to this
I think this should be no surprise to
the regular audience of this podcast
that Google bet pretty big on kubernetes
Sandy Stier a little bit if we kind of
look a little higher up the stack where
the developers of applications on
kubernetes actually are I think to some
degree they just want to write code they
don't want to deal with building
docker images uploading them to registry
deploying different services exposing
them to Internet and all the other
mechanical things that are related to
employing an application so on the end
of the day really key native solves for
the experience of the developer on
kubernetes that would not require them
to know every single aspect of what
kubernetes is and the analogy that villa
villa uses around the low-level kernel
it's spot-on it's kind of something that
we're hoping nobody ever has to think
about when they are developing
applications on key native what's
underneath I have a question so you say
that you don't want developers to be
worrying about every aspect of
kubernetes a much greater load balancer
for instance can eight over would solve
that problem for you like their load
balancer that what to expose new load
balancer kubernetes and my question i
asked because a lot of the problems that
people have it's because you need to
create a docker image so you have a
yellow file there then you have a yellow
file for kubernetes and the skinny have
solved that problem so you have to deal
with different configuration files to do
just one deployment that's an excellent
question
I'm sure VA can speak to the two being
kind of closer a technical side but on a
developer side I think the things that
you will see that directly speak to that
kind of friction that you just described
is being able to skip the entire docker
image as a requirement for somebody who
wants to use key native so we have use
cases where address directly deploying
from a source code and Canada if still
builds that docker image for you behind
the scene but you as a developer don't
have to worry about it furthermore just
like you have pointed out once you
deploy that thing usually people are
excited because the hello world
application comes up but if you're
looking at kind of day two or day five
problems where the application is now
successful and dealing with some of the
auto scaling problems that developers
normally have to deal with this is
another area where candidate really
helps you because you don't have to
think about it's based on auto scaling
and when you audience goes away they so
does the resources they're required to
run your application on top of in Canada
thank you now this sounds really cool so
just to take a step back a little bit in
some ways like we said sort of like
we're deploying things we're deploying
applications like what does that mean to
you am i like deploying Redis
this or what what kind of things am i
deploying that's that's a great question
yeah so typically the first target
market really for Canada is what is
typically the serverless
ake a stateless services it is things
like functions we want to make sure that
you have a very similar user experience
for both or the developer experience for
both of these whether it's an
application or a function so you don't
have to go and have that mental shift
which is oh I'm doing functionally stuff
or I'm doing application e stuff when
typically the lifecycle and the
development processes and practices are
very very similar you have some code
that I would like you to run for me and
don't screw it up please awesome is
there particularly languages that are
supported in caters now or can I bring
my own stack if I want bring your own
stack yeah that's that that's the beauty
of key native the word that we keep
using to describe that is this idiomatic
experience if you were developing
applications you know Java Python
I know c-sharp you bring that same exact
experience and you don't change your
day-to-day operations to kind of adapt
to K native you follow the same
procedures you would develop your
application somewhere else there is no
extra attributes you have to put on top
of your functions there is no extra
configuration inside of your code that
you have to do in order to make it work
for K native Canada this kind of built
an assumption that there is a service
container that we will run and we also
hope you will building that container to
large degree K native is polyglot from
that standpoint anything that can be
containerized can be run on K native as
long as is and right now HTTP
application absolutely sweet so I can
write functions in like Haskell or
something even PHP awesome so if I want
to build like a little K native
application what does that experience
look like how does the tooling work what
does that float look like K native kind
of has two different entry points so to
speak for people kind of familiar
already with kubernetes itself and
they've been kind of used to interacting
with cube CTL the command line for the
CLI for kubernetes
you can just follow the exact same
methodology you build your application
you build your container and you deploy
it except that when when you lands it
kind of lends us
kay native service that inherits a lot
of the properties of the platform it
just explained which is like
auto-scaling and being able to be
configured dynamically and so forth the
routes management if you however you
coming to K native as a developer who
has not worked on top of kubernetes
before there's a growing number of tools
in a community that kind of enable you
to deal directly with the code and not
have to build images yourself so that
use case of a source to URL this one
that we often point to where you develop
the application for example in go and
using the built pipelines that are
developed inside of K native you can
actually execute a pipeline which will
build that code from your repository
private or public and on get or get HAP
and and sock that code and build that
image for you and deploy it so all of
that is happening on the cluster which
gives you a lot of benefits around kind
of obfuscating that or using the
resources only during the built phase
and then being able to use them to host
your application after that how is their
tooling as well for like local
development or do I have to push
everything up to the cloud every time
I'm working we do have some initial
implementation of key native on top of
mini cube obviously some of the
requirements that come with SEO and
kubernetes are a little more resource
hungry but but we have people who have
successfully done that so you could
actually imagine running the entire
stack on your local laptop yes the most
cases you don't even need the entire
stack because you can just really let's
see there just a local web server or run
all your unit tests and integration
tests and everything else and then the
kinds of things that you might not care
about when you do in local development
like well does it scale to zero does it
go away it's like no no it does don't
worry about it just push it in the cloud
and we'll handle that for you so there's
kind of the operational aspect that we
hide for you that you typically don't
necessarily have to worry about when you
doing local development but as Mark
pointed out yeah you can do that with
the mini cube or or anything else and
GCP comes provides developers with a
free tier and I think with our latest
release we actually have a model in
which you could use the free tier to run
small instance single node instance of
key native and G key we list on our
Canada website for features in this case
serving billed events and services all
gone on Jackie I have a question
regarding about events we say here that
would be a universal subscription
delivery and management of events would
be that similar to a pub sub service or
it's a different kind of event what do
you mean but events in here
that's a great question so eventing is
typically lends itself very well the Kay
native execution environment because
it's serving us right so if no events
are happening
aka tree falls in the forest nobody
hears about it right but the event thing
is is a piece that says we want to have
very principal to understand the events
so in a pub sub event for example
happens or a pub somebody publishes an
event into a pub sub you want to say
please execute this function for me and
yes we support that was a direct answer
question but in addition to it it might
be something as somebody pushed some
code to github or somebody uploaded an
image to Google cloud storage or s3 or
whatever else where there's an there's
an action some other system happened and
you even look decoupled those in such a
way that you don't have to understand
how did it happen you just say you know
what when something happens over there
let me know about it
so the eventing you can go ahead and
describe what these events look like and
then you can go and describe strategies
okay what should happen when that event
fires so if you want to do something
simple like thumbnailing
which is pretty classic example you
would say okay when somebody uploads an
image into a cloud storage bucket please
go ahead and run this little piece of
code so that's what the venting concerns
itself with thank you awesome and does
that mean as well that you can extend
that a venting mechanism so if you want
to have your own custom events for I
don't know random things that happen
inside maybe your application or
something could you respond to those
yeah absolutely that's one of the things
that makes me super excited is the fact
that I do think that this model of
computing is going to be made as so much
more approachable to different people if
you have a very reach event in ecosystem
so the more events you have the desire
there is to go and process those and so
forth so being able to go ahead and
create new event sources is something
that we have been thinking about very
hard and making sure that that is very
very easy and it behaves and looks the
same everywhere so I personally would
like to go ahead and
sure that you as a developer again don't
have to worry about reading a whole
bunch of instructions and and clicking
and dragging and copying and pasting
worried to say hey just give me those
events because that that's what I care
about as a developer not about how does
it happen I say give me some events so
you don't need you have Robert a McHugh
running inside K native to be able to
get my events I can use K native itself
to manage those events for me yes one of
the nice things that I like to talk
about eventing that often registers with
with the community or the developers
outside who often don't deal with
Kennedy from daily basis is the
decoupling of the event source from the
actual processing of events so when you
are writing something that's supposed to
act when it's triggered by event you
really don't have any awareness or any
code in your little processor that is
aware of that which means that you can
bind that processor and processing
function to number of different events
as long as that a message type is
defined and this is where key native
also is pretty innovative with regards
to adopting cloud events which is kind
of a common way of defining events
across the internet which is strongly
typing that the different properties
that each event will have while allowing
for extensions of the different data
components that come with that so Canada
supports a cloud event zero to right now
which is the current version of cloud
events and this is where the industry is
collaborating and making sure that we
are able to talk to each other as a
number of different sources increases
over time is that a like an open
standard or something yes it is actually
C and C F I believe project oh I didn't
know about that alright so from the
other side and you touched on it a
little bit earlier like so as a
developer I'm like this sounds awesome I
love it but how do I install this how do
I run this like what is the operator
experience kind of look like here
because this is an open source project
you actually can take the installation
guides that are already published in a
repository and deploy the key native to
any community certified instance of a
service so obviously GCP has a great
kubernetes service called G key but
other cloud service providers also have
that you can also install to your own
kubernetes on premise so the decision
would be basically based on the
two factors one is Dilek alley or a
scene do you need to have applications
somewhere close located to your data
source that's not available somewhere
else or something like that or to the
operational model if you are already
managing your own kubernetes cluster
installing candidate on top of that
would be potentially a nominal set of
scripts that you install and be done
with that however a growing number of
companies are actually not interesting
operating their own kubernetes cluster
the like the common API and the like
that kind of certification across
different cloud service providers but
being able to deploy those applications
on top of that surface and not be locked
into a particular provider so key native
in that case works very well with gke at
next last year so it's been probably
seven months we've launched gke add on
that by including one additional flag or
one check box during the UI provisioning
you can bring the entire key native
stack that's been validated to work for
the particular version of gke
so you out of the box you're getting the
full tentative stack that's already
configured for you and you're ready to
develop your first application as soon
as that stack is available Jiki
currently takes about what three minutes
to provide the entire stack so you have
a pretty quick provisioning capability
for yourself backtracking a bit off and
DXF of the marquee like oh that means
the Cameron Wright is on key native and
really said no it's more stateless
applications right so what kind of
application or code should be not be
running inside of Kay native I'm a big
advocate for not running databases
inside kubernetes because working
stateful applications is complicated so
is that true also 4k native so let me
make sure I understand so you're saying
that stateful applications shouldn't be
running on Kay native I'm asking that
yeah so typically not because one of the
things that we want to do is provide the
pay-as-you-go model so the resources are
not being used typically most stateful
applications require
you have something up and running all
the time however because gain 18 is
built on top of kubernetes one of the
things that you can do is that you can
run all these things alongside
your K native and you just reach out to
the kubernetes directly so I know why
while you might not be a fan of running
stateful applications even at Cooper
Davies if you you do have that that
option because there there is a lot of
great abstractions in the kubernetes SL
and there so you know like standardizing
discs and everything else like that yeah
so with things like that you can go
ahead and get the best of both worlds if
you will it's the developers that really
want to focus on the stateless
applications and em you know functions
and whatnot
they can go ahead and run in the same
cluster they just have a different API
that is a higher level that targets only
the things that they should really have
to worry about thank you well that
actually probably segues nicely into
what I'm thinking about which is so if
I'm running the managed version of K
native do I still have access to a
communities API like the communities
cluster that it's working on or is that
completely hidden from me at that point
in time it is still available to use
when you check that extra box or include
then one extra flag during the g-cloud
command to provision the cluster you're
really not losing any of that kubernetes
capability just adding one extra add-on
on top of that so you still have that
kubernetes api if you wanted to you can
interact directly with Kay native for
the applications that you know don't
require the entire stock but we're
trying to not hide any of the
capabilities that kubernetes has because
obviously it's popular and its really
being adopted by a lot of different
companies so there's no point of doing
this but in the same time for the
developers who don't need to know the
entire scope of the schema for a
particular deployment or service kind of
creating a very well-defined principal
objects that are easy to understand for
developer service route a configuration
is something that just by understanding
the meaning of the word you kind of know
what's supposed to do great credit goes
to the initial thought leaders on this
like Villa and others who kind of
thought about like what would I call
that and what would need to do if I was
a web developer wanted to create
something there so I think that has
proven to be very elegant way of
addressing those common problems that
developers have but if you are not able
to accomplish something that you need
you're not falling very far the the
kubernetes itself is still there
underneath it gives you a comfort to be
able to adapt to the use cases that
Canadian perhaps is not designed for
fantastic if either of you had to choose
one of your favorite features out of
Canada what would you choose
oh that's a good one belay I like scale
to 0 I'm always coming up with Rando
things and I spin things up and then I
forget about them and then I come in
there and I don't have to remember to go
clean up so it's if I if I start some
job a job somewhere and and you know go
home I don't know halfway through home
remember like oh no I left the stove on
my house is gonna burn down
it's like que nadie was gonna just clean
it up or surprise bills yeah surprise
yes exactly
yeah you know it's it's hard to be out
of scaling we often list this on the
same level like many other features but
I think it often goes underappreciated
by even the users of key native because
it's just there and thinks when you
don't look at it it's not there but when
you look at it or somebody else is
looking at and using it it's there so
it's pretty powerful I think the other
thing I would highlight there is that
when we give people the power of ok
native I've seen the easy deploying
applications and people coming from
microservices world where started
starting to deploy 20 30 different
applications on top of that quickly
realizing that maybe not all of them
need to be exposed to the outside world
maybe you should just kind of expose one
UI application or a service in point 4
API and then hide everything else and I
think if with the recent release of 0-3
week or 2 weeks ago of key native we've
added this cluster local provisioning
for services which with a single label
single attribute in a configuration
you're saying this is only to be used by
other services in this cluster not by
anybody outside people already are
talking about appreciating this very
much because it allows them a lot more
flexibility with the type of
applications that deploy on Canada I
wanted to dig a little deeper and on a
scale to zero path something I've
actually just remembered I've always
been thinking about we can ativ so in a
traditional criminales where do you have
pods and you have nose
your cluster but if you have scale to
zero on the functions within K native
what happens to the nodes in that
cluster do you scale the notes to zero
how does that work yeah so in that case
we do not spin the nodes down to zero so
the K native doesn't do that for you so
we just take care of the parts for you
so you would have to do something in
addition to go ahead actually scale the
cluster itself properly to go and bring
the nodes in and out yeah a key native
will deal with optimizing the efficiency
of using your cluster data and by
creating more demand on a physical
resources it gives the signal to
kubernetes to scale horizontally so
kubernetes will see the pressure will
provision a new node and it's probably
not something that dynamically will
happen transparently to the users who
suddenly need to be offloaded to another
node but even then it's getting better
and better with how fast that can be
done behind the scene so you can use the
kubernetes node order scaler in
conjunction networks yes if you if your
cluster is configured for auto scaling
key native will benefit from that just
by running on top of that exactly you
know the only other thing maybe perhaps
adding here in addition to those
features are kind of feel bad for
identifying the cluster lock or nothing
else some of the things that we've done
in gke version of key natives so if you
provision canid if using the gk add-on
you obviously getting the key native
components but you're also getting a lot
of kind of additional service
integration from GP itself you're
getting stock driver integration for
logging some tracing information you get
there you get some monitoring so
increasingly this feels like a fully
managed service even though the
open-source components you have to do a
lot of this yourself in case of GK
add-on it feels like something that you
can kind of say Google this is your
problem solve that for me don't page me
middle of the night when one of the pods
doesn't start I will just write my
applications delay in mark what do I
expect to the feature of K native either
open source or on disappea what we
should expect one of the things that the
working very very hard is is making the
developer experience easy that part I
hope we have convinced the off the other
thing that we are putting a lot of work
into is making sure that the K native
stack itself is manageable so we want to
make sure that
our operator friends either whether it's
at Google or some other companies that
are running and providing the que
natives that that they have the
confidence that the stat can be managed
which means you can go ahead and have
seamless upgrades when new versions roll
out you have a high degree of confidence
that everything is going to go and just
keep on running and everything else so
that's where we are spending a lot of
effort right now that it's not really
developer facing but it's very very
important to me personally is to ensure
that the staff itself can be managed
just a question that pop up now in my
head when you were explaining that you
said that it's going to manage four
versions after days of grades let's say
one thing like spectra happens again
with K native would I have to go
manually patching all my servers or just
is gonna do everything for me and I
don't have to worry about that I just I
just thought about that because we
didn't had that problem recently not we
as we as an IT community and that was a
big problem with with K native help on
that a native itself didn't really help
but it would be taken advantage of
basically the cluster operators that are
providing the underlying cluster so for
example our tireless Google asari
folks would just make sure that it just
goes away so k maybe no but because we
are building on top of kubernetes then
everything that you get from Google
maybes and manage the kubernetes
properly is free out-of-the-box really
standing on the shoulder of giants as we
say that's exactly right and in G key
now we have those flags for auto repair
and a lot of upgrades so if those two
options are check when you're
provisioned k native you are benefiting
from that they're very thing you will
get a control plane upgrade and you will
get out a repair of the nodes fantastic
I think coming back to the you know
future of of K native just doubling down
a little more on what Villa was saying
with zero three release I think we
really have not talked about it this way
publicly but maybe we should a little
more it's probably the very first
release that kind of solves for a lot of
the friction points that we've gotten
feedback from the community so people
when we first announced zero one release
during next in San Francisco there was
you know a few customer
that actually were using that at the
time but the community was still not
providing out of feedback to of actual
real-world use cases over the last seven
months we actually started getting a
meaningful feedback from actual users
people who run that for workloads that
you know I'm not sure their production
but something that is ready to provide
some kind of meaningful feedback with
0/3 release we've actually implemented
many of the solutions from any of the
friction points that we've heard about
from community so you will see kind of
that emphasis going forward going all
the way to the proverbial one all
release which we will hope have soon no
timelines to speak of yet I think that
emphasis on making sure that people are
able to leverage that to build
real-world applications that are not
just hello worlds but something that
helps them solve real problems it's
something that's very close to the
entire team both on the engineering as
well as on the product side we make sure
that those things are addressed or first
of all captured from from the community
through either slack channels that we
use or issues in our github repositories
or even empathy sessions with customers
and trying to kind of observe how they
use that system and then going back and
making sure that those issues are
addressed in our pretty frequent cadence
release which is now every six weeks so
yeah actually to that point you
mentioned slack if people want to get
involved with Kay native or want to
learn more or maybe contribute where
should they go
you should follow via on Twitter first
of all no we do have a public channel so
the official channels are the issues and
comments frankly you don't have to open
an issue you can just open a comment in
repository in github so github calm /ke
native you can also join Kay native
slack calm which is a whole organization
dedicated with number of different
channels for clients or monitoring or
security whatever it's interesting to
you and in native twitter is also a
native project and Twitter's also a good
place to kind of raise concerns or even
ask a question or comment Villa and I
are also under social media points so
just grab a set conference reach out to
anybody on the team and we definitely
love to hear from you yeah and that just
more the community aspect the
conversations that happen in
like and it's it's very very welcoming
and it's fantastic to get new users new
contributors new kicking the tires what
is this thing it's a great community
awesome
well I think actually we were just about
out of time so I think we'll wrap things
up there I think that was great so Villa
mark thank you so much for coming on and
telling us all about Kei native thank
you so much for having this that was a
lot of fun yeah that was great thank you
thank you all thanks again to mock and
Vili for joining us on the podcast to
talk about all the cool things Kay
native but now I have the really hard
questions that I'm gonna ask Gabby about
cloud sequel are you prepared I am
excellent question of the week how long
does it take for cloud sequel to detect
an outage and trigger high Ovilla be
failover how good is our stuff so short
answer 60 seconds
but a lot happened to that to be
detected yeah so every second
the primary instance or your master
depending out the terminology you use
sends a right to our system database
which it is a heartbeat
and if it doesn't attack a heartbeat
signal for 60 seconds it will trigger
the fill over and instead by instance
will be the new primary instance that
you had in there so you always have a
hot standby replica there and that's how
long it takes to activate the fill over
now the fill over may take a bit more
because depends on the replication and
that's a lot of stuff that we can cover
in another podcast awesome sounds like
we should do a whole cloud sequel
episode I hope people want to see that
I'm sure they will
excellent well that's really good to
know fantastic well Gary where are you
gonna be what are you up to you what
cool things you got going on
so this February I'll be talking about
the awesome new features of Mexico 8.0
at b2b ok in London so come out and see
if you want to know the cool tricks
about my secret awesome that sounds
really good I will be at nothing
immediately in the next few weeks I'm
actually need to renew my visa yeah
small details it's a little thing it's
fine
smoggy cow but I am looking forward to
GDC IOB at GDC Game Developers
Conference in March I'm really looking
forward to that there's gonna be a
really big Google presence there we're
gonna have a booth through our
presentations keep an eye out we'll
definitely be talking about that more I
will also be a cloud next as I assume
you will be Gabby yeah yeah
so probably doing various things there
as well so keep that on your radar
database e you'll be doing database
things I'll probably do Ganey things and
also some other stuff and finally it's a
little bit further out but in April I
will be presenting at the East Coast
games conference I'm gonna be talking
about a gun is I'm gonna actually do
some presenting about sort of Arkansas
strategy as well and why I think the
games industry should be doing more
stuff in the open source realm so that
should be kind of fun as well so lots of
good stuff on the horizon a lot of well
Gabby thank you so much for joining me
on the podcast the very first podcast of
the year but thank you so much for
joining me on it I appreciate it thank
you Mark for having me here I hope that
I didn't help anything I know you did a
wonderful job and thanks to you everyone
for listening and we'll see you all next
week see you laters
[Music]
laughs that was gonna happen